alright now here's what I'm gonna do
even though most of you have gotten way
past this I want to go through all the
steps because you didn't actually when
you get to a result like what you've got
and you're like scratching your head
okay you've really got to make sure you
haven't done anything wrong and there
are lots of places and things from your
wrong okay
for starters let's double check this
equation is this actually a legitimate
equation what did I fool all of you is
this at the time is this the time how
would you know you need to check the
geometry right you need to make sure
okay
for instance classic classic example of
doing it wrong okay is that for instance
you might get the Pythagoras wrong like
this might have an 16 - x squared 16
plus okay it's a comedy example okay I'm
making sure you check it okay do you
don't just have said because I told you
okay or you judge this except that
because you came up with it the first
time you looked at the question okay
let's just double check it I'm after
this lengthy right that that rowing
distance okay 16 plus X ray is the
hypotenuse that's right 4 is throwing
speed 4 minus X is this distance okay
because we were trying to debate should
you pick this one is X or this one you
pick that one so okay and 5 is the
walking speed so this equation checks
out that's that's fine I'm enriched
problem you this domain restriction
where do we get that from again
we sorta got it from common sense we
said it wouldn't be yet you would have
to be you would be giving yourself extra
work if you rode to any point outside
here or here that's what that's what
values outside this domain with me right
okay so restrictions okay let's
differentiate now T is what going on
left-hand side instead of like seg-y
okay so it's gonna be DT on DX okay now
here's another place at these gujrat did
you differentiate correct with look at
your steps this change rule involved
here okay
what's it what's it gonna do you'll do
the inside okay so that's gonna be what
2x okay
yeah do the outside so that's gonna be
the powers going to come down right and
then the powers gonna reduce by one so
it's going to become not 1/2 minus 1/2
so it goes on to the denominator
all right does that look right yes that
look okay so far we're right have I used
something
that's is that okay I see here's the
thing right in an exam right well you
don't have someone telling you yeah
these are the steps okay
you've really got to know for sure have
I done this have I differentiated
correctly you're happy okay this is fine
second what do I do over here okay
please don't do question rule okay this
is 4/5 4/5 minus X on five 4/5 minus X 1
5 2 fractions the constant disappears -
excellent fire becomes - okay so far so
good on the top there that half and that
to get rid of those so there's your
derivative yeah so now you want to find
some stationary points right so actually
want to find tiny point so you solve for
that derivative being zero yeah
okay now let's fast forward a little bit
okay because I think Aaron has gotten
the same result you let this equal to
zero so the one-fifth moves over you
cross multiply you square out okay
you're gonna get x equals sixteen on
three yes but that's five and a third
which is outside the domain well let's
let's think about that
let's let's go shoot that so we're okay
I'm gonna get onto the ground fitness
actually I think we can do this you
could graph it but I think you can do it
without a graph if you think no this is
five and a third which is outside the
remit know what does that correspond to
okay that would be I'm going to some
place over here and then I'm
backpedaling hmm now that can't possibly
make sense right because if I'm going
that far and then walking that's got to
take longer then at least rowing
directly right I'm not sure about the
other stuff okay but surely you know
between here and here
rowing directly should be faster right
right okay now what's going on now I'm
trying to dig to the bottom and not just
tell you okay it's wrong it is wrong
okay the stationary point is right you
differentiate a fight okay
what's going on there's two points and
see what's happening because you know
when you have issues with your
stationary points the other thing you
look at are discontinuities are the
stationary points or boundary values
right so let's check him out what are
the barriers
I've got well-defined one zero and four
okay so dry yourself up a little table
time so I know X first okay what value
of x and what time I get as a result
okay so I'm going to test that my end
points zero for just for the sake of it
just to see what's going on I'm gonna
test this stationary point
which is outside the domain now what
happens sure enough these are the values
you by the way you've got to get the
actual values okay what's happening this
is less than that is that's the sound
that happens inside my brain when I get
a this doesn't make sense okay that's
actually what I huh okay now I taught I
told you all my clue was but this part
of the equation was where it breaks down
okay now we said this domain we put it
in place we made it up on the basis that
it shouldn't make sense right but
there's another way that you can think
about it there's another way you can get
this restriction namely that this time
is one component journey
plus another component journey so that
means that both of these things must be
positive right there's no lakes you can
put in here that can make these times
times negative right right these are
times the quantity okay so therefore
this 4 minus X on five okay it must be
greater than or equal to zero right
so pushy or because you want to buy five
okay and then you land on the same thing
okay so it's execrated an equal form is
not just because it makes sense it's
because I'm sorry yeah by the way it's
because not only does it not make sense
but it actually breaks the equation this
equation only tells us the time provided
you stay in the domain once you go
outside this domain okay what happens
four minus five and a third this time
becomes negative right so suddenly
growing further and walking further is
sending you backwards in time now that's
why
this is value is less than this one okay
I'll say it again I'll say it again when
you get outside this domain okay this
part of the equation for my X X on five
no longer tells you a time it tells you
a negative number which is thought
sensical it is telling you that as you
walk further in that direction you take
less time right you think about now
let's go you know X is equal to 100 okay
this is gonna be for minus 100 minus 96
on five so it's like I arrived this is
the I arrived 18 hours ago okay so this
equation that only tells you the time in
this domain outside that domain this is
rubbish this doesn't make sense okay so
therefore what's the answer okay the
answer is well how it actually say the
answer I would say the turning point it
is by the way at 20 points in that stage
it's not just a station when you to
tester you could test a second
derivative but it makes more sense
because it's on the on the denominator
you can have to use question rule just
test first you're gonna - sighs okay
you'll see it's a turning point but the
turning point
well lies outside the domain okay so
this is actually what you write by the
way in your hand side cuz you've got a
account for this number and why you're
going to ignore it I said okay hence the
minimum must occur at an endpoint
okay that's why all right that's why you
can get this value and you're like okay
I've got a disregarded just like you
know actually this value here you had to
be careful because you had to say
execute in zero because you actually get
two values for that you get negative
will you take the square root right but
in the same way you're like well this
answer doesn't make any more sense than
the other hand side right so then you
actually you come back to this okay you
look at these two you like well this
one's better right therefore he should
vote directly to the destination now